after a series of critical tweets during
the day president Trump launched a
verbal attack on the w-h-o in the daily
coronavirus briefing the president
seemed particularly angered by the WH
o--'s recommendation and early february
that international air travel should
continue thus just days after he had
imposed a ban on flights from China he
also appeared to echo allegations that
the organization relied too heavily on
information from China during the
initial phase of the outbreak they
called it wrong they call it wrong they
really they missed the call they could
have called it months earlier they would
have known and they should have known
and they probably did know so we'll be
looking into that very carefully and
we're gonna put a hold on money spent to
the w-h-o we're gonna put a very
powerful hold on it and we're gonna see
it's a great thing if it works but when
they call every shot wrong that's no
good the ban on flights from China was
one of the recommendations a president's
economic adviser made in a memorandum
sent to the National Security Council at
the end of February
Peter Navarro also warned that as many
as 600,000 Americans could lose their
lives Navarro sent a second memorandum a
month later and this time he included
the president on the distribution list
he said that between two and three
million Americans could die he also
specified the medical supplies the
government would need to obtain to
prepare this included a billion face
masks eleven thousand ventilators and
twenty-five thousand respirators the
memorandum was largely ignored
president Trump denies he ever saw the
documents
about this today sure you learned about
the demo today just read about it maybe
a day ago do days ago you feel like
someone is still on your staff or Peter
and borrow himself should've told you
about the no no no there was a
recommendation was a feeling that he had
I think he told certain people in the
staff but it didn't matter I didn't see
it
the president told reporters the
contents of the documents would not have
changed the way he's acted and then left
the briefing after saying he would read
them later Mike Hanna al Jazeera
Washington